well my real food luxury would be a raw
milk Butler he would just bring raw
dairy products including fresh raw milk
to our house once a day would be fine
every other day I could live with but we
go to some time trouble and expense to
get fresh raw milk in our in our
household and then Oh a real food meal I
just love roast chicken and and when I
came off the vegetarian wagon I really
really enjoyed what they call in England
the parson's nose it's the it's the
chicken tail and it's just this fatty
little thing it's delicious so I love a
fresh green salad with high-quality
greens that have been raised in in real
rich soil and have real flavor wheel of
good olive oil I'm happy to spend money
on it gosh I love good blue cheese I
love homemade ice cream and I and I love
to make panna cotta with raw cream which
I haven't done for ages you can actually
just use the little bit of gelatin and
it's a whole raw panna cotta i call it
panic cruda that recipes on my website
somewhere and I love a glass of wine and
I love chocolate so those are a few
things
my guilty pleasure is to eat a big salad
with nuts and cheese and meat day after
day after day and not to make chicken
broth and not to find some good roast
beef so my guilty pleasure is sort of
what I call girl food or single girl
food but there's there's a man at home
and and their children at home and so I
can't just feed them salads with blue
cheese and walnuts day after day my
industrial food guilty pleasure is
definitely white sugar we have not
eliminated white sugar from our
household or our diet but i always
prefer whole and adulterated sugars so
whole unrefined cane sugar or maple
syrup or honey are definitely my
sweeteners of choice but the the dark
chocolate we eat and by dark i mean
seventy percent or higher always
contains a little bit of sugar
preferably organic so i have not
eliminated sugar for my diet and there
are dishes that are just not improved by
maple syrup you know if you want a lemon
meringue pie it just doesn't taste right
sweetened with anything other than sugar
and i love a little dessert I used to
indulge in nonfat frozen yogurt and also
in the sort of imitation grab you get at
salad bars but I now realize that those
are the lowest form of reconstituted
fish meal and the lowest form of dairy
if in fact there's any dairy in it so I
just don't even bother now and I don't
even miss those guilty pleasures
I make some exceptions for eating out
although I I don't really write them
down on a note card but while I would
never ever buy farmed salmon and we have
beautiful wild Alaskan salmon in the
freezer and the cupboard all the time I
I do sometimes find myself eating farms
him and at weddings or on airplanes that
sort of thing one of my pleasures at the
moment after the are three young
children are in bed is to walk down the
street and for 20 minutes have a dozen
oysters and one glass of sparkling wine
at the local joint oysters by the way
are great food for men and women who
would like to be mothers and fathers